the sushi science show clips
so given some of the studies we just
brought up then how would you get about
describing what aging is and the role of
NAD Plus
what is aging Okay so
um
so I think aging is a
um
developmental uh I think aging is
intrinsically linked to development
um and I can defend that in multiple
ways first the strongest
um you know
long-lived mutants that have been
identified in animal systems as diverse
as worms and rodents are loss of
function alleles of
genes involved in growth right so you
know daft2 and Insulin igf
pathway and then the pituitary mutants
in in mice including the
snelled dwarf mice and the Ames work
mice and the pit mice all of these
um
genes that encode growth factor and
growth hormone receptor and
growth hormone releasing factor and so
forth and so on you knock out both
copies and you get very small shrimpy
mice that are infertile
and very long-lived and very cancer
resistant
and so if you mutate growth
you alter the course of Aging
um
I have a difficulty calling those
longevity genes because the genes were
actually conserved for growth and
fertility
and in fact in uh the development of of
animals which is what 750 800 million
years of evolution
um animals evolved to
um be successfully born and to develop
the ability to form motility and
acquiring our own food and then
recognizing mates and avoiding predation
and reproducing and either having lots
of babies
or protecting the smaller number of
babies until they're they can
successfully reproduce and some animals
can only reproduce one time in which
case there's really no selection for
longevity and some uh animals can
reproduce multiple times in which
there's a slight selection for longevity
because let's say a fox that can live
six years
um
might have six times as many you know
Broods
pups or whatever foxes have then one
that that that can only reproduce one
time but is that really longevity or is
it Fox cleverness
that allowed it and Fox sex appeal and
all the other things that allowed that
fox to to reproduce
um you know over six years you know
surviving six Winters it's you know
hunting ability it's a lot of things
so I see longevity the genetic
components of longevity as basically
being emergent properties of selected
trades I don't really see lifespan as a
directed directly selected trades
um there are no dominant longevity genes
that have been identified
um in animals to my knowledge
I have a review article that's coming
out on Friday September 23rd I'm not
quite sure when this YouTube video will
come out but today is September 21 so in
two days from today I have a review
article coming out with over 125
citations the title of which is sirtuins
are not conserved longevity genes I
fully debunk the idea that sirtuins are
dominantly acting conserved longevity
genes from these to
to humans it's just not true
um
The Narrative that sirtuins are the
primary mediators of NAD supplementation
is not evidence-based
um connection between NAD and aging is
that NAD is the linchpin of metabolism
and that our repair capacity and
resiliency declines in aging and many of
those repair and resiliency reactions
depend upon NAD and and all of the
accumulated insults
um involve you know losses to get to the
NAD system so I think there is a use
case for nicotinamide riboside in human
health it may be in fact more important
as we age there's lots of clinical
trials involving NR to test these
hypotheses on evidence-based so
you know you don't see a you know a a
supplement bottle you know behind me as
I speak and and you don't you know you
don't see me getting out ahead of my
skis and saying
you're making
um fanciful claims about uh extending
human lifespan but I'm excited about the
clinical trials that are being done with
NR because what it does you know in Road
systems is so powerful
and although we tend to like very
striking quantitative phenotypes like
protection from heart failure so we tend
to do shorter term experiments and then
sacrifice the animals and then look at
mechanisms as opposed to doing two and
three year long experiments and looking
at you know life and death things but
other people are doing those things as
well so I'm excited for the field but I
think that one of the problems is that
it's deeply contaminated
with uh some statements that are just
not evidence-based at all like the idea
that sirtoons or longevity genes is not
evidence-based at all and I and I and
and and and
so I think it's it's very problematic
and I spend a lot of time trying to you
know educate people on that